it's not a plea any parent wants to make
ever let alone at this time of year Tim
Edwards is distraught a man inconsolable
after having his daughter Ellie snatch
from him in a brutal murder on Christmas
Eve she loved life and had so many
amazing plans for the future words he
wrote too difficult to speak Christmas
and our family will never be the same
again without her
she was the glue that held this big
family together
we will love and miss her forever our
Ellie May the most beautiful and bright
star out there
the 26 year old beautician was out with
her sister and Friends celebrating in a
busy Pub but just 10 minutes before
Christmas Day
[Applause]
a gunman fired 12 shots towards the
front entrance of the lighthouse Inn
killing Ellie and injuring four others
police say they will not rest in getting
Justice for Ellie's family they've
spoken to a number of witnesses viewed
vast amounts of CCTV but they are still
searching for the dark Mercedes which
left this car park just minutes after
the attack and the gun that was used to
murder innocentelli
these people don't deserve to be walking
our streets they don't deserve to be
protected they belong in prison
we know that the answers to this lie
within our communities so my appeal to
you is please tell us what you know and
help us get Justice for Ellie's family
following this arrest on Wednesday
police have kept a 31 year old man in
custody on suspicion of conspiracy to
murder they've released a 19 year old
woman on bail and the 30 year old man
who was held on suspicion of murder is
out of custody and recalled to prison
as the investigation continues people in
Wallace Village have tried to return to
normality the blocked off-road now open
businesses back to Trading
but outside the lighthouse Inn which
will remain shut until at least New
Year's Day
Ellie's car still parked untouched just
meters away from where she was killed
the love for Ellie is clear not only
through the hundreds of flowers and
messages left for her but the tributes
posted by friends and family online
[Music]
but it was the courage of her father
wanting to show his face wanting people
to hear his words that may help bring
Justice for this hurting family into man
Rasheed Sky News the world